-All right now,
here's how it works.
Joel, you'll start the game by
pressing start on this buzzer.
It's the only button here.
[ Light laughter ]
And then, you draw a clue from
the top of the pile.
You have to get your teammate,
Michael,
to guess the clue as quickly
as possible.
Then hand the buzzer off to
the person on your right.
You can make any physical
gesture,
you can say whatever you want,
but you can't say any word in
the actual clue.
If you're holding the buzzer
when it goes off,
your team loses that round.
We're going to play three
rounds.
Joel, you're there.
-Okay.
-And Michael, you're over here,
offset.
Your across from me, buddy.
Dude, are you good at this?
-Yeah, let's get 'em.
-Whoo.
-This is tense.
-Whoo! Here we go.
All right, Joel, when you're
ready, press the button
and we will begin the game.
-Here we go.
-Mm-hmm.
-So I grab this --
at the same time I press
the button?
Yep, you're going.
-Oh, I'm going.
[ Beeping ]
This is what people wear on
their heads in Texas.
-Hats
Cowboy hat.
-Mm-hmm.
-Wait, that was great.
All right, good.
-Cheer!
[ Cheers ]
Shop top.
-Raindrop.
-Yeah!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, white girls wear this
to look like black girls?
-Bikini?
-Don't guess. Don't guess.
You're on my team.
-Look like Trump did this a lot.
-Toner?
Spray tan, spray tan.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Uh -- if someone --
-Take your time.
-You're gonna need one to watch
the child when you --
-Babysitter.
-Yeah, that's right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a thing, when you pierce
this.
-Your tongue?
Tongue ring!
-Yep.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Zombie!
If we got -- sleep walking?
-Yeah.
-Oh, man.
That was good.
All right, good.
All right.
Big deal. Big deal.
You got that one.
That's cool.
Congratulations.
And thanks so much for coming to
the show.
-What? That's --
[ Laughter ]
-You thought we were playing
another -- no, all right.
Let's go play another round.
Here we go.
-Let's go.
-All right.
All right.
-We can do this.
-Come on.
[ Beeping ]
-Okay. Um --
You can't eat it --
it's microwaveable.
-Burrito.
-Lunch!
Lunchtime.
-Tacos.
-There's a song.
-Pizza.
-♪ Something in the morning ♪
♪ Something in the evening ♪
♪ Something at supper time ♪
♪ When that -- on a something ♪
♪ You can have that any time ♪
-Bourbon?
-Oh, come on, man!
-Lemonade?
-It's Italian and Jewish.
Two good cuisines come together
and make beautiful harmony.
It's got a hole in the middle.
-A donut.
A bagel.
-Yeah, but what also --
-A pizza bagel?
-There you go!
[ Cheers ]
-Slow motion?
-Yes.
-Yes, sir!
[ Cheers ]
-This is something that you take
out -- plants you don't want
on your lawn -- and they grow.
-Weeds.
-Yeah, and what do you --
-Weed whacker!
-Yes!
[ Cheers ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-You're choking!
-Why were you choking yourself?
-He choked on that.
[ Laughter ]
-I couldn't say it. I --
-He choked on that one.
-Yeah, yeah.
-All right, here we go.
Last round, good luck.
-Ready?
-Yeah.
-All right.
[ Beeping ]
-Oh, okay.
You do this at a bar.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
-Like --
-"Stairway to Heaven," there's
a real long one in
"Stairway to Heaven."
In rock songs.
And that's how they show off.
-Guitar solo?
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do this in bars?
-I don't know.
-Okay, this is something you
don't really want anyone taking
a picture of you eating.
It's a -- it's on a stick.
-Corndog, corndog.
-Yeah, that's right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, sir!
-That's exactly it!
-This is the guy that will walk
up behind you and rob you
and you don't even know it.
-Me.
[ Laughter ]
Pickpocket! Pickpocket!
-Yes!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Me.
[ Buzzer ]
We lost that one.
You guys win.
The champs, but it's all right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Our thanks to Joel McHale,
Michael Che.
-In your face!
-In my face right there.
Offset!
And we'll get it next time.